It's possible to enjoy San Francisco year-round,...
...but you might want to consider the city's unusual weather when planning your trip.
Summers are usually chilly, with daily highs often below 70.
Fog keeps it from getting sunny for most of the day...
...and winds coming off the Pacific will make you shiver.
Spring will be better in terms of crowds and prices,...
...but don't expect dry, warm, comfortable days.
If you don't mind carrying an umbrella,...
...winter is a great time to visit San Francisco.
It will be windy and rainy, but it rarely actually freezes and storms are unusual.
But the very best time to visit is in the fall,...
...which is often the warmest and sunniest season.
Fall is also outside of peak tourist season,...
...making it less expensive and less crowded.
Whenever you visit, you'll need to bring a jacket.
Even in the warmer months, it tends to get cold quickly as evening sets in.